the apple loves to surprise people it's
pretty clear that the next iPhone will
be much faster on the internet it will
be a 3g phone this is something that is
not my great intuition this is because
Steve Jobs has said it and I've heard
that you could you might be able to do
some cool things with that speed for
example for the first time live
real-time video chat on your cell phone
that would be interesting although the
truth is about video phones that no
one's ever in the real world been that
interested in them they sell video
phones but the truth is in the real
world when you're on the phone you want
to be doing other things you can pick
your nose and be cleaning house be doing
the dishes and the other person doesn't
know I'm not sure people want to see
each other but anyway that's
you